por el momento hay al menos 32 muertos
pero hay más de 100 heridos con lo cual
se podrían lamentar más víctimas
mortales en las próximas horas ha sido
un accidente de tren el choque de dos
trenes a la altura de soja al sur del
país muy cerca de la ciudad turística de
luxor las autoridades egipcias en un
comunicado dijeron que se podría haber
tratado de un accidente causado al tirar
a alguien del freno de emergencia
ocasionar la parada de uno de los trenes
que el otro tren habría embestido al
circular por la misma vía en dirección
norte ambos iban en dirección norte uno
desde luxor hasta alejandría y el otro
desde acá desde asuán hacia hacia el
cayo es muy habitual que se produzcan
por desgracia de este tipo de accidentes
hace solamente tres años se produjo otro
accidente grave en el que murieron 40
personas y hace solamente dos años hubo
un incendio en la misma estación de
ramsés la principal
la capital del cairo con lo cual es muy
importante que se mejoren las
infraestructuras y es el motivo por el
cual el ministro de transporte el
ministro del turismo se reunieron la
semana pasada quieren mejorar las
infraestructuras ferroviarias que
utilizan muchos egipcios pero que
también ayudarían a impulsar el turismo
en esta zona que como digo está llena de
reliquias y de antigüedades y que
habitualmente visitan muchos turistas